DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Hello, everybody.
Thank you having us.
MALE SPEAKER: Of
course, welcome.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
This is awesome.
Awesomely, awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: So welcome.
Welcome.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Now, I
just want to start.
I brought my little
cheat sheet here.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: Of course.
All right.
MALE SPEAKER: You
have done it all
You're a legendary musician.
First rap group to appear on
the cover of Rolling Stone.
First to appear on MTV.
Rock and Roll Hall of Famer.
Grammy nominations.
Emmy awards.
Founder of the nonprofit
The Felix Organization.
You've spoken at the
White House, to Congress.
You're a best selling author.
But now DMC stands for something
beyond Darryl McDaniels,
beyond the devastating
mic controller.
Now DMC stands for
Darryl Makes Comics.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: Yes, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: How
did we get there?
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
How did we get there?
What people don't realize is,
before music changed my life,
before-- first it
was rock and roll.
Then it was hip hop.
But before music
changed my life,
my whole existence was school.
I went to Catholic
school my whole life.
MALE SPEAKER: Me too.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Huh?
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Yeah.
Catholic school is cool.
I was a straight A plus,
plus, plus student.
I like to brag about that.
I was always on honor roll.
But at that time of Kenny
Garner in the eighth grade,
it was school and comic books.
And the reason why comic
books were so important to me
is a couple of reasons.
Going to Catholic school
in Hollis, Queens,
the public school
kids thought this.
Oh, you got a uniform on.
Your mother and father paid
for you to go to school.
So you're rich.
Run it.
So I go bullied.
I got my money taken weekly.
To get from my house to
the school was terrible.
It was just horror because
I knew I had to go outside.
But once I made it safely to
school, all was incredible.
I loved reading and writing.
I loved the first day of school.
I loved new pencils and pencil
sharpeners and book bags
and all of that.
But when the school day
ended, I was terrified again
because I had to go back home.
But when I got home,
after I did my schoolwork,
Marvel comic books
empowered, educated me,
gave me confidence to exist
in the so-called real world.
It also helped me
with my studies.
The reason why I believe
I was such a good student
was, even back in
the '60s and '70s,
there's something wrong with
the nerdy little kids that
read comic books.
Remember every educators was
like the comics is bad for you.
But they didn't know about this.
Because I was reading.
You know what I'm saying?
They wanted you to
read the World Book
Encyclopedia and the
Encyclopedia Britannica,
which I did.
I read the World Book
Encyclopedia Volume One to Z.
My mother thought I was crazy.
But that was because
of comic books.
And the reason why I excelled
and my school work was
so good, in school,
in history, you learn
about World War II, right?
But Captain America
takes you there.
In science, you learn about
the now eight planets.
A little kid corrected me.
There's only eight
planets now, Mr. DMC
because Pluto's not a planet.
I say, good thinking.
You know, you learn
about the galaxy.
But the Silver Surfer
takes you there.
So because I was
reading comic books,
I was able to excel in school.
But also, it just took me to
a place that where I was safe.
And comic books was
my whole existence.
Also I was a little kid who
grew up in New York City.
I was one of those kids that
when that light come on,
you have your butt
in this house.
So I was a little kid
living in New York that
didn't get to see New York.
DC was cool.
Gotham, Metropolis, right?
We always talk about this.
Well, Marvel was in New York.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
It was in Queens,
it was in Manhattan.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: I saw
the Empire State Building.
The first time I learned about
the Roosevelt Island tram
was in Spider-Man.
And then I remember the day, the
first time I went to the city,
and saw it, I was shook.
Oh, my god.
That thing really exists.
So comic books was my
whole real world as a kid.
MALE SPEAKER: And in DMC
number one, you of course,
are now DMC, the superhero
in New York City,
1980s, New York City,
alternate reality.
So what made us go there?
Is that--
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
Well, all right, we
talked about this a lot,
because the thing about Darryl
is that like he just kind
of like prefaced by saying,
it kind of like was all
part of his existence.
And what he forgot to mention,
is that they were also
the gateway to hip hop for him.
Like his brother actually
broke the bad news to him
and told him,
they're going to have
to sell their entire comic
book collection because they
needed to get into this
new thing called hip hop.
And they sold their
comic book collection
and bought their first
turntable and the mic
MALE SPEAKER: That worked out.
EDGARDO MIRANDA RODRIGUEZ:
and a microphone.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Everybody always say that.
That is the first
thing people say.
Good thing it worked out.
EDGARDO MIRANDA RODRIGUEZ: D
and I talked about this a lot.
Because we were thinking,
well, what if we kind
of like look at it from a
science fiction storytelling
perspective?
We love alternate realities
and the concept of that.
So we said, what if in this
alternate reality, D tells me,
I never picked up
the microphone.
And what if, in this
alternate reality,
it's kind of like the presence
of supernatural forces do
exist and I'm imbued by some
mysterious superhero heroic
powers.
So then I thought,
well then, we have
to paint a whole other universe.
It shouldn't be simply as
DMC, the superhero in 2015.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
That's corny.
EDGARDO MIRANDA
RODRIGUEZ: Right,
so we were like, well, what if
we go back to the height of Run
DMC's like, fame and
the height of Run DMC,
and also the birth of
hip hop and everything
that was like fresh
in New York City,
even as recently as Madonna
on the Jimmy Fallon show
stated that New York City,
in terms of its flavor,
was at its height in the '80s.
And this is before shiny,
you know, condos existed.
There was hit pop.
There was punk rock.
There was disco.
There were B-Boys, graffiti,
graffiti all over trains,
from artists like Lee
Quinones even Basquiat.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Keith Haring!
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ: Why
don't we create a comic book
that kind of reflects this
kind of like very rich, raw--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Powerful, creative,
time period.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ: So
we said, let's go back to DMC,
back in 1985, he doesn't
actually become an MC.
He finishes at St. John's
and he gets himself
a master's degree in education.
But by night, he's a superhero.
And we said, and
New York City needs
to be the second
character in the book.
And my background, I work
with a lot of graffiti writers
and comic book artists.
So I said, well then we
need to actually inject
some authentic graffiti
art into the actual book.
We're not just going to get a
penciller to kind of like mimic
or emulate the graffiti, no.
We actually had the
penciller do the panels.
And then we will
pass the artwork
on to all these wildstyle
graffiti artists.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Real graffiti writers.
EDGARDO
MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ: I mean,
the cover that you see right
now on the wall is actually
like the vision of four
different artists, [INAUDIBLE]
directed it.
Sal Buscema, who's a comic
artist who we both grew up on--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Legend.
EDGARDO MIRANDA
RODRIGUEZ: drew it.
Bob Wiacek inked it.
Carlos Mayer, Mayer 139,
actually did the Wild Style
graffiti and they
all worked together
and then it was digitally
colored by Chris Sotomayor.
So our book kind of like had
to embrace this kind of era.
Because it was fresh for
us, and what we realized
is that in this age right
now, especially young people,
there's this kind of like vibe
for reflecting an era before.
And that's kind
of always existed.
I mean we were growing up, in
the '70s and '80s for example,
people look back to
the '60s and '50s.
So now, it's only like regular
that people looking back
to the '90s and '80s here now.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: And the '80s
was the best period of all.
And old school
wasn't a time period.
It was a consciousness.
It was a way for
people, especially here
in New York City, to
creatively present yourself.
Like when I do speakings at
high schools and middle schools,
hip hop didn't just
create rappers.
It didn't just create a bunch
of DMCs and Chuck Ds and Jay Zs.
It created people such as him.
You know what I'm
saying, he's an activist.
He's an art director.
You know what I'm saying?
He's a writer that created
doctors, lawyers, designers,
educators.
So when we were young people,
growing up in this universe
was nothing.
It's almost like all of
us in this room, all of us
back in the '70s and '80s,
regardless of how desolate
our lives were, we
all had a super power,
some of the kids got on the mic.
That was the power.
Some of the other
kids. they knew music.
That was the DJ.
Some of the kids that
couldn't even read and write.
There was kids that
would say, I don't even
know nothing about music.
I can not write a rhyme.
I can't read and write.
Hip hop didn't discriminate.
It said, what could you do.
But what I hear that
guy recite his poetry,
when that guy plays his music,
I feel like spinning on my head.
We didn't, oh, we got to
save money for a lifetime
to build a disco.
We were too young to
get in the discos.
It was like, hey,
go cut that box up.
Throw it on the floor.
We had a dance floor.
So it was very
innovative at that time,
you know what I'm saying.
And when we first started
out, even the powers
that be in the
music business, they
would say, oh, rap's a fad.
It's going to be over
and this and that.
Jay always something that
was really powerful to me.
EDGARDO MIRANDA
RODRIGUEZ: Jam Master Jay.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: He said
or without the record business,
there was always
going to be hip hop.
There was always
going to be artists.
going to be writers.
There was always
going to be DJs.
And you know for me, like
I said, it wasn't just me.
My neighborhood was the Bronx.
It was Brooklyn.
It was other kids all over
the world at that time.
And what had happened
to me was, we
started hearing
Grandmaster Flash.
We started hearing Afrika
Bambaataa, the break
dances, rock steady crew,
the way they dressed,
the way they look.
Grandmaster Flash and the
First Five and Afrika Bambaataa
used to dress like Run DMC.
But when they got
into show business
and started making records,
because it was show business,
they kind of changed
the representation of,
not who they were, but
their presentation.
The first rappers didn't have
wrappers to look up to them.
So when they got into
the record business,
if you look at Grandmaster
Flash and Afrika
Bambaataa and those
first records,
they looked like
the Rolling Stones.
Rick James and
Parliament Funkadelic
because those were their idols.
When Run DMC came along, before
they were making records,
Melle Mel and them
wore Pumas and Adidas
and sheepskins and gazelles and
track suits and all of that.
So our idols were flashing them
before the record business.
And me and Ed always
talk about this,
the B-Boys were like
superheroes already.
The DJs were like, they
had names like superheroes
and stuff like that.
And what made me such a perfect
fit for Ed when he said,
yo, we going to do this and
create this universe, actually
how this came about is, I went
to-- he couldn't be here today.
I went to have a music meeting
with Riggs Morales, who
was from Shady Records, the
whole success of Eminem,
he was there at
that [INAUDIBLE].
So I go to meet about
music and Riggs,
in his professional
voice, he says,
yo, I ain't really supposed
to fan out right now.
I usually keep it
real professional,
but you're DMC, man, and when I
was growing up, this and that.
And it was like, you guys
were like my superheroes.
And he just asked
me, D, how was it
when you was-- what was it
like when you was a little kid.
And just like I told you, I'm
sitting in this music meeting.
Well, um, I went
to Catholic school
my whole life and all I
did was read comic books.
And when I said the word comic
books, this light came on.
The heavens opened
up. and the angels
started blowing their trumpets.
We're supposed to be talking
about a music meeting.
The artist that we was there
representing was pissed.
EDGARDO MIRANDA
RODRIGUEZ: Poor guy,man.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
We sat there for two hours
and talked about comic books.
And then he said,
D, did you ever
think about doing a comic book?
And I was like, you know, I
thought about it, but you know,
I don't want to be corny.
I don't want to
be another rapper,
just because I'm successful,
trying to do something.
I like to stay in my lane.
And he looked at me
and he said this to me.
He say, yo, what happened
when you put hip hop-- you
and your boys put hip pop
with rock and roll, huh?
You put the hip hop-- not
with "Walk This Way" first.
You took "Rock Box," which
was the first rock rap
record to be on MTV.
Something good, right?
Then you all did
"King of Rock," right?
Then you all actually
got with Aerosmith
and did "Walk This
Way" and that changed,
that didn't just change music.
Busta Rhymes said, they changed
everything, fashion, style,
the relationship of black
people and white people.
I would say, yeah,
that was good.
He said, what happens when you,
with your boys, took hip hop
and talked about your sneakers.
You launched this whole
sneaker culture, this and that
and the reason why
rappers get deals today
is because of what you did.
I guess we kind of did that.
He said, yo, the
only thing that can
happen if you
create a comic book,
it could do the
same thing that you
did with your music, the same
thing you did with your hip
hop, your style, your fashion,
you could put all that energy
in this book.
Then he said this to me. this
is what really got me to say,
OK, I'll try it.
He said, yo, but don't do it
as DMC, the famous celebrity
rapper guy.
Do it as little
Darryl McDaniels,
the kid who loved
comic books first.
And I said, OK, cool.
Then he just basically said,
next week, come to my office.
I got somebody I
want you to meet.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
And then Riggs
brings me over to the meeting.
He just started
as Vice President
over at Atlantic Records.
And I bring my son,
[? Keyon ?] with me
and we think we're just
going to have lunch and all.
And he says, you know, I can't
have this lunch because I
had a lot of stuff on my plate.
But I'm going to walk you
down to this board room.
Because there's somebody in
there I've got for you to meet.
And we walk up to these gigantic
15 foot high cherry wood doors.
And he grabs the
doorknob, and he
says, whatever you do, you
go in there, don't fan out.
And I'm like, who the hell is
on the other side of this door.
So I'm like, OK, I got
to keep my game on.
I don't even know
what I'm talking about
and who I'm talking
about this with.
And we opened the door, there
is D with his big Kool-Aid smile
on the other side of the
door, like mad excited.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Cause he
was like this is the comic book
guy, right?
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
I had no idea what we were
about to talk about, right?
And then he goes into
this whole story.
Catholic school kid, straight
As across my forehead.
And he tells me the
whole-- my brother,
he made me sell my comic
books so we could get--
and it was just like
an amazing story.
Two, three hours
later, literally, it
turned into like a
three hour meeting.
And [? Keyon ?] is on the
side, reading his comic books,
just kind of like tuned out.
But that's our target audience.
So we're kind of like
thinking about this.
And we realized we
need to literally think
about this more.
And I told him from the
beginning, I was like, look,
I could help you
do this, but you
need to do this for yourself.
You need to stand on
your own two feet.
Eric was there.
He's our manager now.
And I was like, Eric, talk
to your lawyer and stuff
like that.
And set up your own LLC.
Whether you work with me or
not, set up your own company.
Because this is your
intellectual property.
And it shouldn't
be that you take
this idea that somebody else--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
DC or Marvel.
EDGARDO MIRANDA
RODRIGUEZ: that they
could take it and
take it from you
and reinterpret it
in their own vision.
And at that point,
I asked Darryl,
I said, what would you even call
your own publishing company?
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Ding.
Darryl Makes Comics.
That was easy.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ: And
then like, even a month later,
a few weeks later,
we meet up because he
was shooting a commercial
that was produced by A-Trak.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: With A-Trak.
EDGARDO MIRANDA
RODRIGUEZ: Right, right.
And he brought together Run and
they were doing a song together
for the commercial.
And it was being shot
like a music video.
And Darryl invites
me over and he says,
yo, yo, come down
to the video shoot.
It's kind of cool.
You check it out
and besides, I've
got to talk to you
about some stuff.
We're in the green room,
just me and him talking,
and he starts doing,
yo, I can't sleep.
My wife is worried.
Man, I been thinking about
this comic book thing.
And I'm thinking to myself,
he probably has so much
on his plate.
He probably just wants
to tell me nicely
he's going to just dead this
project from the beginning.
And he was like, so
I just need to let
you know that I can't
do this project,
but I need to do it with you.
And I was like what?
And he was like, I can't
do this project unless you
want to be my partner.
And we got to bring
Riggs as a partner too.
And that's how we actually
founded Darryl Makes Comics.
And it was that idea.
And then for the next
two hours after that,
we just geeked out and started
talking about comic books
all over again.
We were like little
kids all over again.
I pulled out my phone and
I'm going to Google Images.
Look at this cover
of a white tiger.
Oh, my gosh,
remember "Iron Fist."
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Remember "The Defenders." stuff
that people don't
even-- everybody's
so caught up on
what's in the movies,
not "Captain America"
and "Avengers."
But it was this whole universe.
And the cool thing is,
all three of us sat there,
and we said, if we're
going to do this,
the most important element
of this publication
is it's done when integrity.
And it's done as a
tribute and celebration
of those things that could
change people's lives.
And even deeper
than that, we also
created this to
make sure that we
gave all writers, anchors,
pencillers an opportunities.
Even to the point
where I'm 51 years old.
So there's probably
a guy who should
have joined for Marvel or DC
and never got their chance.
We want to give
them their chance.
There's young people,
you know what I'm saying,
there's kids and young
people, there's women.
So we wanted to be
completely diverse.
And Riggs was like, yo, this is
going to be easy for all three
of us, because we are the
people, all of the ideas,
concepts, images, all
the issues, Ed was like,
we gotta deal with
the issues, politics,
and religion is
afraid to talk about.
Not in a negative
way, just to sell it,
like to really talk about it.
We want to tell
people's real stories.
In the first issue, when
all this stuff was going on
in the NFL, you know, with the
players fighting the women,
there's those elements in there.
People actually thought we
saw the NFL thing and said,
we're going to do this.
No, we thought all this out.
We want to talk
about these things
before they become big issues,
so we could prevent it.
Whether people know
it or not, when
rap was-- when hip hop was
first starting in the '80s,
you had Run and
DMC saying be cool.
Go to school.
Don't mess with drugs
and you'll be cool.
You had Public Enemy
saying, fight the power.
You had Paris One
saying teach yourself.
The thing about our universe,
even though it was F'd up,
there was poverty, crime,
people killing each other
in gang fights and all
that, we were good.
We were using our style.
He walk in there
with those sneakers,
and you going to look at him.
Now is this attractive?
But then when you walk over
and talk to Ed as a young man,
you're not going to get the B
word and the ho word and this
and that, and what's
up [INAUDIBLE]
word and stuff like that.
You'll be able to talk
about something good.
And it goes back to the point
where even those kids that were
in the gangs, even the pimps
and the pushers in our era,
if they saw creativity
and positivity--
You know, people used to
tell me and Run, you all
got to get off that corner.
You all going places.
You don't need to be out here.
I'm looking at this
world we live in now,
America celebrates stupidity,
ignorance, and illiteracy.
The more trouble you
get, the more women you
sleep with, the more stupid
stuff you do, you celebrate it,
especially if it makes us money.
Our world was kind of different.
We've even made iced tea
and all these guys said, wo,
there's power in positivity.
And that's what this
book represents.
Use your creative.
Use your mind.
Use your soul.
You know what I'm saying?
Enjoy what you're doing but
with that with your flavor,
you can really change the world.
I mean Run DMC did it,
but there's no Run DMC
if there was no Grandmaster
Flash telling you broken glass
everywhere.
[INAUDIBLE]
There's no vision if
[INAUDIBLE] see the message was,
this is messed up.
But then Afrika Bambaataa,
which was the biggest street
gang in New York, right
they were the Black Spades.
They changed their name to the
Zulu Nation to be positive.
And they make the record
Planet Rock with the vision,
we know a place
where it's all right.
So this place here
is that place,
even though it looks crazy.
But here's the deeper question.
We threw a wrench to y'all.
Is it the '80s?
EDGARDO MIRANDA RODRIGUEZ:
Because one of the things
we wanted to play with,
kind of like looking
at other comic
cultures, like you
had-- the best example
is Bruce Timm, who
created the entire
Batman animated universe.
And here it is like,
you're watching the show,
and you're like, am I watching
a show based in the 1930s
or is this right now?
So what we wanted to do is kind
of like take a tip of the hat
to that, tip of the
black crown to that.
Because we were like, well
you know, everyone always
feels that in literature or
even comic book, graphic novel
storytelling, that
the only period
you can actually pay tribute
to is the '20s or the '30s.
It's the noir era.
So we were like we'll
create-- F that.
We're going to create our
own era to give tribute to.
And it's going to be the '80s.
So we're going to create a
universe that looks like 1980s
New York.
And it turns out,
technology, only
if it's organically
woven into the story,
doesn't have to be, because
technology as we all
know in this room,
continually is evolving,
you know what I mean.
So our universe is definitely,
like an homage, like Darryl
was saying, to this era
that we all grew up in,
is a richer story.
And also from a superhero
storytelling point,
it makes more sense than a
city that looks like this
and this era needs saving.
When you look at a city
now, with like shiny condos
everywhere, it's like, you
know what needs saving?
Can you save me an
apartment with cheaper rent?
I don't know.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Exactly.
EDGARDO MIRANDA RODRIGUEZ:
And then one of the things
we did, obviously the
story is one thing,
but one of the things that
we're doing and embracing
is-- and Riggs actually
coined this phrase,
we're embracing what we're now
calling the B-Boy geek era.
Because what a lot of
people don't realize,
there's a lot of individuals,
such as Darryl and myself,
we are where we
are in our careers.
But there's still that nerd
side of us that is who we are.
We were persecuted
for being different.
We were persecuted for
liking different things.
But yet here we
are, creating an era
and creating a kind of
like our own contribution
to pop culture with our
book in our own way.
And we call it the B-Boy geek.
You know, because it's is
something that we appreciate.
It's something that we respect.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
And those things are cool.
It's cool to be a geek and
be creative and be smart.
Not to be afraid to express
what you like in life.
I'm proud that my son
and my wife are geeks.
MALE SPEAKER: Probably a lot
of smart people in this room.
So we're actually going to
open it up to some questions.
We have microphones in both
the aisles if you guys--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Superman
and Batman were having a fight.
Giving me an inspiration
for a song I can write.
Now when I came along as
the son of the [INAUDIBLE]
my physical form is
how I celebrate life.
No, I don't need a preacher
and I don't need to preach.
Just give me mellow Moe Dee
on the beat with the speech.
I've got a good reputation
because I rep for the streets.
And for your information
I am King of the Geeks.
I get to speak hard because
I hit the beat hard.
It's DMC, y'all and I'm
in the streets hard.
You see this belt buckle?
I wear it all day, so
every time that you see me,
I am chilling with J.
[APPLAUSE]
Geeks rule.
People are geeks.
MALE SPEAKER: Step up to the mic
if you have a question, please.
Thank you.
That was awesome.
AUDIENCE: So as
you're aware, Marvel's
coming up with a bunch of
crossover classic hip hop--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Yes.
Album covers.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I was wondering if any
of your records are--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Yes.
Can't tell you which
one, but it's coming.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
I can't tell.
AUDIENCE: Which one
would you like if it
wasn't the one that you wanted?
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: Excuse me?
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
He said which one would you
like it to be?
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: Oh, yeah.
EDGARDO MIRANDA RODRIGUEZ:
Nah, nah, nah, nah.
That's not going to fly.
Sorry, bro.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: All of them.
All of them.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
The thing
that it is-- can I
see the graphic novel?
The thing that's
dope about that is
that-- OK, we love and we
grew up on comics, Marvel, DC,
and everything like that.
So the fact that Marvel is
doing a tribute to hip hop,
I think, it's
fresh, because it's
kind of like a full circle.
And in the back of our
graphic novel, all we did
is give tribute in our
way to Marvel Comics.
So it's like a
full circle for us.
Like this is a Jim Steranko
Hulk annual number one
that we reinterpreted.
This is a "Web of Spiderman"
number one that we interpreted.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
It's a "Wolverine."
We took all of their stuff
and did me as their covers.
EDGARDO MIRANDA
RODRIGUEZ: So the fact
that they're doing that, that
just shows us and shows them
that there's actually mutual
love and mutual respect
and you know what, its pop
culture loving pop culture.
Because DC Comics did
it early in the year.
DC Comics actually did
variance of all these movies.
They redid "Superfly,"
"Superman."
They redid Bruce Lee's
"Enter the Dragon"
with Grayson, Dick Grayson.
So I think it's fresh.
I think it's dope that
they're doing that.
MALE SPEAKER: What's up buddy?
AUDIENCE: Dude, it is
so cool to meet you man.
I was born the year that
your namesake, album Run DMC
came out, and like to become a
fan once like, I could talk--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Where you from?
AUDIENCE: Originally Florida.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: OK.
Right on.
AUDIENCE: It was really
cool to like experience Run
DMC in the '90s when I was
like becoming a fan of music.
So thank you from the
bottom of my heart.
That led to-- actually
I have two questions.
First, was like part
of your contract
that you have to wear Adidas
every time you're with Darryl?
[LAUGHTER]
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
It would be wise to.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ: The
thing about Adidas and Run DMC
is that because of Run DMC,
Run DMC were the first group
to get an endorsement deal
with a sneaker company that
were non-athletic.
And that happened
one day, was it
when you guys were
doing a Philly show?
And it was like, 65,000--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Yeah,
yeah, and we'd tell people,
hold your Adidas up and the
whole concept held up Adidas.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
So if that
doesn't show the power of the
consumer to a corporation.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
This the first time,
like usually when you do hip
hop, when you see hip pop
comics or cartoons,
they'll have a sneaker
with two stripes or one
stripe that looks like Adidas.
This is the first time--
EDGARDO MIRANDA
RODRIGUEZ: Adidas
is on a comic book cover.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
On a comic book cover.
That's crazy.
That's how real we wanted to be.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ: But D
does a lot of work with Adidas.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: Yeah, yeah.
Adidas, three stripes for life.
I can't go nowhere.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
Brand loyalty right here.
AUDIENCE: That's amazing, man.
That might be like the
longest shoe endorsement.
And my second question,
you were talking
about how hip hop not only
gave rise to the music,
but to graffiti, to--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, writers, directors.
AUDIENCE: Break
dancing, et cetera.
And it also gave rise to the
fifth element of hip hop, which
is beatboxing.
In this very room, actually
won the talent show,
the Google talent show
for the beatboxing.
I do, "It's Tricky."
I also do "Walk This Way."
EDGARDO MIRANDA RODRIGUEZ:
You got to do it.
[RAPPING "IT'S TRICKY"]
[APPLAUSE]
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Come
on up here and give me some.
Give me some.
That was bad, man.
Darryl McDaniels,
ladies and gentlemen.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
That was awesome.
AUDIENCE: That was the most
fun I'm going to have all week
and it's not even
1:00 on a Monday.
Thank you.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
You know, it's funny.
If you know it's
funny too, I remember
when Ed and Riggs was
really trying to convince
me to do this comic book.
And now, people that's
picking up the comic book,
they're a going back to
listen to the early records.
In 1985, when we did "King
of Rock--" "King of Rock,"
if you listen, there's
a line in there
where Run knew he wanted
to be the best MC.
If you all know the movie
"Krush Groove," Run,
he actually acted
that in the movie.
But that was his personality.
That was his drive.
F you, Russel.
This and that.
I'm Run.
I'm going to be--
Who's house is there?
All of that was in there.
Everything in the movie
is who Run is as a person.
If you listen to the record,
Run used to be Kurtis Blow's DJ.
He was Kurtis Blow's
disco son DJ Run.
So he knew how to
DJ really good.
He knew how to rap.
Kurtis Blow would say,
ladies and gentlemen, I'm
going to bring out
my disco son, DJ Run.
And Run would come out at
12 years old, kick a rhyme
and get on a turntable.
Cutest thing ever.
So in King of Rock, there's
a rhyme where Run goes,
I'm DJ Run.
I can scratch.
I don't go, I'm DMC, I can rap.
I'm DMC, I can draw.
Even in 19-- it was almost
like it took 1986 for me
to put down my
pencil where I used
to draw all the covers of
Marvel and stuff like that
and go full time with the mic.
But if you listen
the King of Rock,
if you listen to
all my records--
remember I was telling
you about my confidence.
When I made my first
record, I didn't
know you had to get up
in front of people to it.
I was a shy little kid.
that I'm thinking, OK, I'll
made this record with you, Joe,
because if they play
a record on the radio,
nobody got to see you, right?
So they played the
record on Mr. Magic,
and Red Alert every weekend.
And they started playing
it during the week.
And then the record
became a hit.
So Run calls me, yo,
we got to go on tour.
And this was '84 with
the first two singles
that we started making.
Run was like, we're
going to make this album.
And we're going to make another
album, whatever, whatever.
If you listen to "King of Rock,"
if you listen all my lyrics,
my delivery, my style, my
presence, crash through walls,
come through floors,
bust through ceilings,
knock down doors.
That's all superhero writing.
Marvel Comics.
The amazing description,
"Spiderman" title,
"The Incredible Hulk," the
devastating mind-controlling
DMC.
My whole presence, my whole
delivery, my whole existence,
my whole confidence, came
from those sacred, beautiful,
artistic, ideological,
if that's a word,
to the point where, I think
it was like 15 years ago,
Rolling Stone
Magazine did a thing.
EDGARDO MIRANDA RODRIGUEZ: And
they interviewed Chris Rock.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Run DMC,
what's the big fucking deal?
So they asked journalists
and writers and everybody,
other MCs, you know, what
do you like about Run DMC?
Why were they able
to do what they do?
Chris Rock said this.
This is 15 years ago.
He goes, Run and J were cool.
But DMC, he was
like my superhero.
The way he sounded, his
delivery, and the way he
looked and dressed.
And my joke was, oh my
god, I've been discovered.
Because I'm really a superhero.
So don't let the book fool
you, it's just a cover.
I was just about to
go down in the world
when Ed and Riggs is going to
release me to save the world.
But you know, all
of those elements
was there and that all
came from the comic book.
That all came from,
you know, Chuck D, when
me and Jam Master
Jay, rest in peace,
when we first heard Chuck D
out at Adelphi University,
people don't know that
Chuck D was a graphic art
student at Adelphi
University, high honors.
When we walked into
WBAU radio station,
they have this little
college radio station,
I just got to put this in here.
This is the funniest thing.
Our first interview ever was
with Hank Shockley, Keith
Shockley, Chuck D, Mr.
Bill, Bill Stephanie
out at Adelphi University,
before they were public,
they were Spectrum City.
So we get our first interview.
We trot up from Hollis
to Adelphi University
in Long Island.
When we walked in there,
the first thing we saw
was this black dude with
a clock on his neck,
answering the phone, going, yo,
G. With a styrofoam of chicken
wings.
That was Flavor Flav.
But I remember when we
heard Chuck D's music,
we heard Chuck D's voice, and
we ran to Rick Reuben and Russel
and we said, God has
come down from heaven.
So there was always these
super powerful-- and the break
dancers with their
skills and the voices
of Melle Mel and Chuck D, all
of those things were relevant.
And it was just amazing
how Chris Rock felt it.
Now people's going back
and listening to my music
and saying, oh,
we understand why
DMC was so devastating, because
it all came from comic books.
AUDIENCE: I don't
know how I'm going
to follow on for the last act.
You sabotaged me, man.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
You have to stand
on your head or something.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: Thanks, first
of all for coming.
This is amazing.
We get a lot of cool
people that come here,
but this is definitely
right up there.
So thanks a lot
for being with us.
My question is around
one of the comments
you made around
negativity in America,
potentially the
world, celebrating
negativity and number
of-- all the bad things
you mentioned before.
What does the sort of
artist that you guys
look at in today's era
of hip hop or music
on a broader perspective
that are actually
keeping it real to the essence
of what hip pop stood for?
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
Well, I still look at--
AUDIENCE: Or people that
inspire you right now.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
In the hip hop,
I still look
outside of just MCs.
Rock Steady Crew to me is still
like a model of positivity.
One of my close
friends, Crazy Legs,
he does international
work with Rock City Crew.
He's taught B-Boy classes
from like Latin America
to countries in Africa.
And I look at what
graffiti writers are doing,
like Mare 139 actually curates
a lot of art exhibitions
where he actually
brings in children
and he shares the
culture in that way.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
And spoken word.
Like when you go to
a spoken word event,
you hear about
the issues, right?
And you hear from
people's heart.
That's what hip hop used to be.
Now don't get me wrong.
You can get your money
and you can have your fun,
but hip hop is a little
different from any other part
of show business.
I mean not too different
from rock and roll,
but it's a little different
from any other music business
because hip hop is
different because there's
a responsibility.
There's a responsibility.
When you think of the term
so-called gangster rap.
You know, Ginger Baker, I just
saw the documentary of Ginger
Baker and it was amazing.
Because he said,
the fucking music.
You don't put my
fucking music in a box.
I remember there was an
interview with Q-tip or Talib,
one of them.
It was like, took it like, what
do you mean, backpack rapper?
I'm a rapper that raps
about positive stuff.
So once we started doing
that-- and that only happened
to legitimize negativity.
To give it a turn, it's
going to be gangster rap.
So if you do gangster rap,
you're making money, it's cool.
No, it's wrong.
And only thing that will
make a gangster record right
is, on that very
record, you tell
the kids, on that very record
of verse, the next verse
should be, don't use the gun.
You could tell your story.
That was the difference.
We cared about the audience.
You know, right
now what I'm really
listening to is classic rock.
Classic rock doesn't mean old.
Classic means better
than everything that
comes after it for eternity.
And the reason why I
was-- No, it's true.
I say that on the radio.
They always go, turn it off.
Say that again.
But the reason why it's
better than everything
after it, because
think about what
was happening in
the '50s and '60s
still happening now, right?
All of the issues.
The thing that was cool
about hip hop is, see,
it's a little different now.
Somebody will hear, you
know Jeru the Damaja record,
and go, that Little
Wayne or T.I. is using,
and go, why that guy
using Little Wayne record?
No.
Little Wayne and
T.I. Got it from him.
But Jeru got it from Miles
Davis or Grover Washington
or whatever.
One of the things
that we did when
we were sampling and stealing
from the very institution that
allowed hip hop to be
inducted in the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame, we
stole all your music.
Made our own songs about it.
But when we sample Lennon
or when we sample Dylan,
or when we sample Fogerty,
we didn't just say,
oh, these guys are
rich rock stars.
Then we start reading,
oh, shit, John Lennon
slept naked at the protests
of the Vietnam War.
We knew we had a
responsibility there.
These kids now, they don't know.
I'm telling you, you
can get your money
and go to all the
parties that you Well,
when you make a full album
of throwing up gang signs
and saying negativity,
your audience
is going to look
for what's next.
Is hip hop
responsibility to give
When you listen to Geto Boy's
"Mind Playing Tricks on Me,"
Scarface wasn't saying-- I
don't want to say no names.
Like the guys now, hip hop
is like stupid America,
just because they're selling
records and they're on TMZ
and they're on
Entertainment Tonight.
You know, they take
names from Mafia figures
and [INAUDIBLE] and drug lords,
I always got to check the kids.
I said, this guy
don't have an army.
He not a drug lord.
He don't own territory.
He's probably selling drugs
in a five block radius
of your own neighborhood.
He's the reason why
your mom is on crack
and your father's in jail.
And the kids go, geez!
And then the don't
have nothing to do.
But when you listen to
"Scarface" or "Mind Playing
Tricks on You," he said,
at night, I can't sleep.
I don't want to
sell these drugs.
I'm in church, Lord, I'm
looking for answers and stuff
like that.
Nowadays, it's almost like I
hate when "Time Magazine," I'm
talking about the most powerful
publications and institutions,
they'll talk about successful
rappers from the hood.
And they'll go, former drug
dealer, former crack dealer,
now CEO of a record
company or liquor store,
it makes them-- without
explaining this to them,
they go, wow, I could
sell crack and be famous.
That's what our
kids really think.
They see a rapper nowadays
on TV, how many times he done
got arrested.
They drive a Lamborghini.
Here is the most
stupidest thing.
Got a Lamborghini.
You ain't got no license.
You ain't got no
license plates on it.
You got unlicensed weapons.
And pounds of weed in there.
But the kids are seeing that
because of who they are,
they thinking that's cool.
And it's wrong.
At least, you know
Scarface and the X-Clan,
even Ice-T had
morals to his story.
And I remember
when I rapped, I'm
DMC in a place to be, I
knew I had a responsibility.
But I wasn't the first to do it.
Here's something.
Before rap records--
he lived in that era.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm the all powerful
mighty DMC, but one
of the things that makes
this publication work is he
comes from the Bronx.
I grew up in suburban
lower middle class Queens.
I had to walk three blocks
to get what he-- He told me
about getting evicted.
The heat being off.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ: I
walked through the broken glass
everywhere.
People pissing on the corner
like they just don't care.
The message was my reality.
I walked through vacant lots.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
He saw that every day,
but still we had
this creativity.
I was in my little world
and I was identifying that.
So one of the things
that happened to me
was-- and this goes along
with the whole responsibility
thing and the power.
Before Kool Moe Dee, you
all heard of Kool Moe Dee?
Remember the infamous battle
of Kool Moe Dee and LL
in the '90s?
That whole how do
you like me now?
EDGARDO MIRANDA
RODRIGUEZ: Google it.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: Yeah,
Google it if you don't know.
LL and Kool Moe Dee
had a historic battle.
Well, before Kool Moe Dee
was successful solo artist,
commercially
successful in hip, he
was in this group called
The Treacherous Three MCs.
This is before rap records.
And in my era, let's
just say that when
people ask me, who's better Jay
Z or Eminem, back in the day,
it was who better, Kool
Moe Dee or Melle Mel?
So Treacherous Three invented
the fast rap, all of this stuff
that our generations
don't know about.
But here's this little
kid, Catholic school kid,
from lower suburban
middle class Queens,
I get this Treacherous Three
record and Obama's campaign
was called, yes, we can, right?
Remember when he first came,
it was called, yes, we can.
In 1982, the Treacherous Three
made a record called, Yes, We
Can Can.
And they took The Pointer
Sisters song, (SINGING)
I know we can make it.
I know that we can.
I know darn well.
that we could work it out.
Oh, yes we can can.
Doobadoobadoob.
And they was kicking
rhymes about everything.
And the record
started like this.
This is '82.
(SINGING) Evil
destruction, tax deduction,
price inflation rocks the
nation and unemployment
is on the rise.
It's hard to find a compromise.
But if it lasts like this
for a long enough time,
won't lead to nothing but
a higher level of crime.
So we say-- and then
they just went and talked
about the problems
that existed then.
Go play that record now.
Everything happening
there, happening now.
But then I got to the point
where the MC break off and do
their freestyle.
So Kool Moe Dee was
just known for being
the Eminem of our era.
He'll battle you and
disrespectful you and make
you want to just leave New York
and never show your face again.
But he knew he had
enough responsibility,
and this is the rap
that changed my life.
And it's about, this is not
about censorship and censorship
and what's the other word?
Telling people what they can
say or what they can't do.
This is about genocide.
It's about genocide.
So he says this rhyme.
He goes, once a nobody
from the neighborhood
took a hop to the
top because I knew
that I would excel over the
rest because I make progress.
I don't consider it luck
because I'm not blessed.
He said, I've got my
life full together.
Love the way that I live.
Go to school, really cool.
And I think positive because
this so right to have fun.
Lots of pleasures
enjoyed but it's
brain that separates
the men from the boys.
So here's this little
Catholic school
comic book reading
nerd hearing Kool Moe
Dee from the dirty, ill,
war torn Bronx saying
it's cool to go to school.
Then I did more
research, found out he
was a straight A student.
Found out that he was
in college and all that.
So when I got my time
to shine with Run.
And Run said, DMC and if you're
ready, people rock steady.
Driving big cars.
Get your gas from Getty.
I ain't going to
rhyme about no gangs.
I was never in a gang.
I ain't going to
rhyme about jail.
I've never been to jail.
And I tell kids,
I don't want to go
to jail because I like freedom.
I tell kids, I
ain't shoot nobody.
I don't want to get shot
because that shit hurts.
And the kids always laugh.
But when it was my time, I said
I'm DMC in the place to be.
I go with that power
and the energy.
I go to St John's University.
Since kindergarten, I
acquired the knowledge.
After 12th grade, I went
straight to college.
Here's how I want to
answer your question.
15 years later, 15
years later, I'm
just talking about the power
of taking that responsibility.
Little steps do big things.
15 later I'm at a
radio interview.
Guy calls in.
You know how you go
to hip hop stations.
You get calls, you take calls.
Who this?
Yeah, this is Peanut
from Dallas, Texas.
Yo, DMC, man.
I just want to tell
you something, man.
Just for you LL, Public Enemy,
Run DMC, Will Smith, Jazzy
Jeff, saying, what
you're saying,
just for-- you all didn't
preach it to us, you're saying,
you said it with conviction.
He said, man, I was gangbanging.
I was selling weed.
So here goes my hero,
my superhero, DMC,
telling me school is cool.
He said, I thought I had it all.
I had Adidas with no laces.
I had the Gazelles.
I had the big old chain.
I had the Mercedes Benz.
I was selling weed.
I had my girls and all that.
DMC's talking about he went
to St John's University.
He said, just so he could
really have the total package.
Not only with the
weed and the liquor
and all of that and the cars
and the Adidas and the stuff
like the Gazelle.
He said, man I went and got
a GED, just so I could say,
man, I got a total package.
That's hip hop.
He's thinking, man, to be
that awesome, I need that.
The negative stuff,
that's the low stuff.
I got to have that.
He said, man, when
I got that GED, I
was able to take college courses
at the local community college.
He said, when I
walked in those doors,
I saw a whole world of
possibility that I never seen.
Now hip hop nowadays
is not showing the kids
the whole world of possibility.
You know, and all of you
all know when you see,
when you look at Sports Center,
most of our kids either think,
I can be a drug dealer
or I can be a gangbanger
or I could be an athlete.
Me and Ed want to
let these kids know,
I don't care if you live
in the dirt poor ghetto,
you can go work at Google, dude.
You know what I'm saying?
Don't be ashamed that
you like to color.
You know what I'm saying?
Don't be ashamed that you like
polka dots and all of that.
That's what this
book represents.
That's what our art
represents about.
There's a lot artists out there
should be played on the radio.
But they don't.
In thinking about that, I don't
believe a conspiracy theories.
But think about old school.
And think about this.
Thing about old school at noon.
I go like this.
I'd prefer that there wasn't
an old school at noon.
The radio will go, no,
that's giving tribute to you.
You should be proud of that.
I say, I prefer if you
don't play my music at all
if you gonna do that.
And they go why?
Think about this, you all.
When they play the
old school at noon,
I'm talking about kids,
when-- I'm 51 years old.
But when I changed
the world, I was
the age of all the rappers
in the audience out now.
Right?
So when you play me
old school at noon,
during the weekdays, two things.
Where are the kids?
In school.
Where the parents?
At work.
When the kids get
out of school at 3:00
and they turn the radio
on, what do they hear?
All that stuff that they
shouldn't be hearing.
They need to hear somebody 16,
17, 18, and 19 talking like PE,
Chuck D, Geto Boys and
Will Smith, but they don't.
So I'm like, how
can I conquer that?
I could sit here all day and
curse out the radio stations.
But I'm saying, I
could say tomorrow,
let's go to every radio
station in the United States
that play that crap
that's poisoning
the other part of the brain
that the kids can use.
I'm not saying that they can't
have fun and go and smoke
the weed.
Cause the part of the brain
that's not being touched,
I could say that nobody
going to show up.
So how me, Ed, and Riggs
going to counter that?
We're going to take them
to the universe that's
going to do something
when they open
the pages of the
book the same way
that it did something to
a little Catholic school
kid, that not only
was successful in rap,
but was able to
change the world.
The groups that need
to be on the radio 24/7
and ain't, that's who I'm
saying we knew as young people,
hip hop isn't just about--
you can be a rapper right now.
You might not even get hurt.
You've got the
best message ever.
So I mean, we're part of that.
You guys is part of that.
You guys is part of telling
all these little kids.
All right, it's
good that you've got
your mixed tape but come
over here and let me show you
something.
People showed us stuff.
And we had to take
upon ourselves,
how are we going to present
ourselves creatively,
artistically, or, like
Ed, intellectually.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
So even with our publishing
company, we take a very
socially responsible approach
to everything that we're doing.
It isn't simply about
storytelling for profit's sake.
It's storytelling
for posterity's sake.
You know, I look at my son
and I look at my nephews,
and I want to tell stories that
I'm proud that they can share,
and they can read, and that they
can share with their friends.
And my son, [? Keyon, ?] is
constantly giving me ideas.
We should do this.
You should lose this character.
And it gives me
so much pride when
he can come into the studio and
actually see on the big screens
all of the different
panels that we're
working out for the next book.
Because it's not a
fad for us either.
This is our first
book, but we're
in knee deep production
for our second book.
And again, like as
fans of the industry,
I get to work with a lot of
legends, a lot of young talent
that never had an opportunity,
like Darryl was saying.
And a lot of like
talent in general.
Like the next book
has talent that
ranges from artists
in their early 20s
to artists in their
40s, some of which are--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Amy's writing.
EDGARDO MIRANDA
RODRIGUEZ: Right.
We have like Amy
Chu, she's writing
the second graphic novel.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: Cause dudes
don't know, without women,
we wouldn't be here.
We gotta come from somewhere.
Where's that energy coming from?
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
That diversity
for us is organic
to our storytelling.
So it's a socially responsible
approach to the books.
And in terms of what
we're listening to,
what I'm listening to,
it's not so much artists.
Occasionally, out I'll check out
a dope song, the Kendrick Lamar
song, the Black of the Cherry.
I mean that was dope.
Lupe Fiasco has a
lot of dope stuff.
My favorite group right now
consistently making music
is Calle 13 straight
from Puerto Rico.
They're like the most
politically, lyrically amazing
lyricists out there.
And they're like, I'm just
going to rhyme in Spanish.
And I love it.
That's like--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Be who you are.
Any more questions?
MALE SPEAKER: We have
time for one more.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
Short answer, bro.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: I got you.
I got you.
So, D, I have to
say, growing up,
you were one of my big heroes.
I'm a Jersey boy, goes
to camp, somebody hits
play on the boom box
and it's "Hard Times."
Almost knocked me over.
No stopping there.
And I hate to end
on sort of a downer,
but I have to say
that I'm not sure what
happened with Jam Master Jay,
but it was a very sad day.
I don't know if--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Yeah, I'll talk about that.
Yeah, definitely.
I mean people always ask me now.
They go, man, Run DMC
never glorified violence.
You know, we ain't
big of negativity.
We only said like, three curse
words out of all our albums
and stuff like that.
How could that happen to Jay?
Now the very thing that Jam
Master Jay made it away from,
he went back to his neighborhood
to deliver everybody else
from--
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
That was beautiful.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: He
could have had his studio in LA
around the block from Dr. Dre's.
We live in Queens.
He could have had his
studio around the corner
from Diddy's house,
whatever it's called,
he changes his name so much.
His studio, right?
I don't know, Diddy's house,
Daddy's house, Shawn's house.
His studio was five minutes
from where he grew up.
He went back to say,
this is the door.
I don't know how we
going to figure this out.
I don't care if you can't rhyme.
You going to be secretary.
You going to be accountant.
He went back.
I describe it like this.
And this is what our
world has to understand.
I'm not mad at the guy that
shot Jam Master Jay in the head
and killed him.
How could you-- man, I'm
not mad at that individual.
I'm mad at the mindset
that would cause that guy
to shoot Jam Master Jay.
That's what I'm going to fight.
That's what I'm
fighting against.
That's why I wear
this belt every day.
Jay came from the hood.
One thing you could
say about Jay,
he was that dude in Hollis
that didn't let the thugs mess
with the nerd.
If Jay was playing
ball in the park
and he seen the nerd
about to get robbed,
he saw prosperity in that nerd.
Yo, yo, yo, no, man, come on,
put that-- yo, go home, man.
He was that dude.
So that was the physical Jay.
So people need to understand.
How could you not be mad?
Don't be mad at the people
that do what they do.
What could we utilize
to change that so we
don't think like that.
You know what I'm saying?
Because it was a crazy loss
because the first thing you
think is, Jay never
said, I'm going
to get shot a million times.
And I'm bang bang.
None of that was in it.
The very thing that
he made it away from,
he took and went
back to deliver.
So once we teach these kids
self-respect and vision.
What Jay represents,
that with the gun.
All Jay is that guy
that didn't use the fun.
When me and Run came to
Jay, we said this to Jay.
Jay was the number one DJ
in Hollis, Queens, New York.
He had the Hollis crew.
Jay was in the gang.
Our gang was, Jay
was in the gang,
but one thing Jay didn't do,
he didn't let the gang mess
with lesser forces
of something that
had vision and stuff like that.
So me and Run go to
Jay and go, yo, Jay.
Run goes to Jay and goes,
Darryl-- Jay knew of me,
but he didn't know me.
He said, me and Darryl
McDaniels from 197th Street
made us a record.
We need a DJ.
You want to be our DJ?
We'll going to go
around the world
and we going to do some gigs
and we're going to get paid.
And Jay's question was this.
He said, hold up, you mean,
because he was doing it
for free every day.
You mean, you going to
pay me money to do what
I'm doing in the park for free?
I'm packing my bag.
Let's go.
And he was able to go.
And one thing about Jay, when we
win city to city, town to town,
if we went to Kansas, if
we went to Germany, if we
went to Japan, we would
meet people in the mall.
Or we would meet people at
sound check, that very night,
because Jay loved video
games, those people
would be in Jay's
room playing with him.
So that spirit is what
we're trying to keep alive.
That's what my whole thing
is, hip hop didn't just
create rappers.
You know what I'm saying?
Hip hop created people that's
up here in the beat box.
You got a beat box
that work at Google.
Doug E. Fresh would
be proud of that.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
And as a tribute to Jay,
what a lot of people
don't know about Run DMC,
it was actually Jam
Master Jay that actually
gave Run DMC their distinct
look, the shell toe
Superstars with no laces.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: The leather.
EDGARDO MIRANDA RODRIGUEZ:
Leather pants, black fedoras,
the fat gold chain.
And as a tribute to that, I get
chills just think about it--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Because people always go,
why Run ain't in
the book and Jay is?
I never meet Run
in this universe.
Not a rapper.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
I came up with this idea,
And I was like, Jay did that
for you guys in reality.
So what if Jay is
our Quatermain?
What if he's Q?
What if Jay--
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
James Brown has a--
EDGARDO MIRANDA RODRIGUEZ:
gave you your suit.
And in the comic book,
we see Jam Master Jay.
Ooh, I get emotional.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: You're
going to get to that part.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
It's our tribute.
We love what he stood for,
and what he did for the group,
and what he did for culture.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: He was
our style and he was our music.
There there's no show if we
didn't have Jam Master Jay.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
And its Jay
that actually gives a DMC his
superhero costume forever.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
So he's here with us.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
He's always with us.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
And to sum it up.
Those are things that
we'll fight-- I tell kids,
we created hip hop to
go against everything
that's celebrated in it.
You know what I'm saying?
It's crazy that you
don't need a gun.
You don't need a posse.
You don't need to go get high.
I remember Chuck
D told-- there was
Run DMC, Eric B and Rakim, Jazzy
Jeff, and the Fresh Prince,
EPMD.
Yeah, it was Eric B. and Rakim,
Run DMC, EPMD, and Jazzy Jeff,
and the Fresh Prince,
we was on tour.
This was 1987.
We was playing coliseums
and stuff like that.
And Chuck said two
powerful things
and we can end on this note.
He says, you know what's
the most powerful thing
about this hip hop thing?
What, Chuck?
He says, it's not the fact that
we're getting all this money.
It's not the fact that we're
making all these records.
making videos now, running
them, setting it up so
we can get sneaker deals,
and we can get endorsements
and stuff like that
and we could do movies.
Because we did "Krush
Groove" and stuff, whatever.
He said, it's the power
of our communication.
It's the power that there's
always a mic in front of us.
We're always on TV,
videos, and records.
When that mic is
in front of you,
say something
that's going to make
the guy that loves you all's art
say, man, I could be something.
And this and that.
And I remember I was
standing there with my 40
ounce of Old English.
I didn't like smoking weed.
Run and Jay smoked more
weed than Bob Marley.
Weed made me get paranoid
and think too much.
You know alcohol, I mean
I been sober 10 years,
was my serum, my
super strength serum.
But then Chuck D--
something came up.
Chuck said, I'll never
forget the that DMC said,
man, when I get rich, I'm going
to have a faucet in my house
that pours out Old English.
And Joe would say, I'm going to
have a weed plantation and this
and that.
And I forgot how
this came up, and I
remembered Chuck D-- and this is
good for nerds and clean minds.
You don't got to drink,
you don't got to smoke,
you don't got to sleep
with a lot of women.
You don't got to have more cars
than everybody and go to jail.
Chuck, we was talking about
weed and stuff like that
and he's going around the
room, and it came to Chuck.
And Chuck is 22 years old.
He just basically
said, man, I never
got high a day in my life.
Now this is how naive I was.
I'm standing with my 40 ounce.
Imagine if you could hear my
thoughts when he said that.
How the fuck do you
rhyme that good?
And I went back to my room and
I said there for like a week,
trying to figure out,
how do you do that?
I mean now that I've been
sober, I understand now.
But when he said that-- so we
want to remove misconceptions
about us nerds.
Nerds rule.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ: And
I've been clean my whole life.
I never smoked weed.
Never drank any
alcohol and stuff.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: I
think I'm attracted to you.
Something very Chuck
D-ish about you.
EDGARDO
MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ: I want
to say that one thing that is
amazing about working with D
is, obviously he's this icon.
I grew up listening to Run DMC.
I had the Run DMC Adidas apparel
when I was in high school.
There's no pretense
to this dude.
He's the most humble guy.
When we work together, it's like
I'm with 13-year old Darryl.
DMC not even in the room is.
It's 13-year old Darryl.
And one thing that's amazing
about his transformative life
is that at 35, when he
found out he was adopted,
instead of like crumbling,
he took his power
and he focused within.
He turned his life around.
He gave up drinking.
He gave up drugs.
He became straight.
He co-founded a foundation that
works with foster children.
He dedicated his life
to philanthropic work.
And Eric tells me this a lot,
when D put down the bottle,
his mind opened.
His mouth opened.
And it was because of this
DMC that you see here today
that we started this
publishing company.
Because the DMC that exists
now that is straight,
does philanthropic work,
it's constantly making music,
and is an amazing storyteller,
and more than anything else
is an amazing friend.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS:
Thank you, man.
MALE SPEAKER: You guys, thank
you so much for being here.
DARRYL "DMC" MCDANIELS: I'll
do pictures and autographs
for those that can't get them.
MALE SPEAKER: If you guys want
to hang out, line up over here.
If you got your books come out.
We'll take some pictures
and sign some autographs.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Guys,
thank you so much.
EDGARDO MIRANDA-RODRIGUEZ:
Thank you, man.